it will be Fatah at the same time down
to three so yeah alright so this one's
gonna focus on the attacks that seem to
be most effective against missed post
quantum crypto candidates that are based
on lattices there's of course lots of
general reasons to care about doing
algorithm analysis but I think for this
audience don't really need to advertise
analysis is an important thing
especially analysis of cryptographic
systems where if you analyze the cost of
algorithms to attack those systems then
you're providing advice to designers of
the systems and to users of those
systems but for us we just care about
you know we want to know how fast the
algorithms are because it's
intellectually challenging so the the
algorithms that we're talking about our
algorithms to break various lattice
problems I should say in terms of
credits the the stuff we're going to
talk about is based heavily on a survey
and sage script from a 20-19 document
which is from us and from Chechen
opportunity on self and christina von
britain all right so if you want to have
any concrete parameters so if you want
to have like equipped a system in mind
to break it then you can't think of the
submission that this is from so let's
see streamline intro climb documented
this is our middle security level where
we're going for this ring up there so
these are polynomials of degree less
than 761 with coefficients modulus Q and
then whenever there's something showing
up which is low weight then low weight
means well weight 262 at 86 so the
targets for the attacker are to find
some a which is in this ring and not
just low weight but it's even that all
coefficients are in 0 plus and minus 1
so it is small in each of the entries
and there are only 7 at 86 of those we
can start writing that's why we give him
the talk together right great
only 7 286 of those are said
and so then problem one is that you are
as a tag and given a public element from
this ring you
is in this ring modular Q so the entries
are between well either 0 and 90 or you
can go symmetric around 0 and you know
that there is another small element e
this time the weight is not restricted
but each of the coefficients is between
plus 1 0 and minus 1 and that gives 0 so
that is problem 1 that they take our
faces and we're gonna show on the next
slides how this relates to some other
crypto systems now then it's demonic
task and also talk oh right and talk at
the same time yeah so problem number 2
is you're also trying to find this small
weight W secret a in the ring and you're
again given some big G in the ring
modulo Q and you're given that modulo Q
I you have AG plus e is well something
it's no longer required to be 0 there's
again some small secret e beyond the a
that you're trying to find you're given
a G Plus e but again this problem 1 is
only the the special case of the day G
plus C equals 0 all right so if you can
break problem - well then you're also
completing one and then there's also
problem 3 which appears naturally in
souther systems which is basically just
like you're seeing multiple outputs of
problem 2 is one way of seeing it so
both of these the same a different G's
and then different small vectors e1 e2
now it might be just several of these
problem two statements or it might be
that they have different distributions
so it really depends on the situation
which system be attacking whether these
all follow the same level of smallness
but the one thing you know is it's the
same thing and just if you're curious
about how much we can prove about the
relationship between these problems and
try to compress them down to just one
problem why do we have three different
problems to begin with then well problem
- as Tonya mentioned gives you a
solution to problem 1 if you can solve
problem - all the time on the other hand
if you can only solve problem to say 99%
of the time for some distribution of
AIDS and genes and needs that somebody
tells you that doesn't mean that you
could solve it for for problem 1
maybe problem one is more sick
problem - well okay the attacks will see
later they seem like basically the same
problem from two versus problem three
there maybe there's a closer
relationship if you can solve problem -
for whatever distribution of a G's and
E's then you can solve problem three for
that distribution if you just forget
about the g2 and E - well you have an
example problem - oh forget about the
other one whichever is closer to your
problem - yeah okay
so then I promise that this will be
related to some other crypto systems so
and true or our streamlined and true
prime solution what you're given is well
this equation up there in probably one
this is zero it's not proximation so
it's AG plus e equals something and for
intro this is just zero and the G the
public value given is the fraction of
two small entries so a is the thing
which is small and controlled in weight
and E is the one which is just small and
then you give me a key there's a minus
sign here appears but it's a fraction of
those two things all right another
example where you have the same kind of
approximation a to some multiple of this
G where you also know what the G is is
scripta systems that are is maybe a
little confusing because there's a ring
LWB problem there's also ring lwe crypto
system and in that crypto system the
public keys are well two parts you're
given some random G and you're given
some approximation to a G what little a
times you've been a big a it's another
part of your public key that's little a
times big G + E which I mean you're also
given that up here the difference is
that the the G and this system is chosen
randomly whereas before the a G Plus D
was required to be zero which limits
your choices we are going to use some
different names for these systems to
avoid confusion with the ring L to be
problem and to emphasize the overlap in
for example the ciphertext and the
structure of this AG equation that
you're given we're going to use an N
true name for both of these systems
where the distinction between the
systems will be well what you see in the
computations here there's a quotient for
that first system and a product for the
second one so from now on it'll be
quotient entry for the first system
product entry for the
second and then in the quotient entry
system if you want to encrypt it simply
do the following you're given as input
some small ring element beat some small
ring element D and then you simply
multiply well there's some factor 3
which if you exercise decrypt then
you'll see why the 3 is there you
multiply basically multiply G by D
ignoring the 3 all right then you
multiply by 3 then add D and that gives
you some B which is your cipher text and
you can see here just to relate this to
to the problems you can see here that
the problem of if if G were random which
was not exactly but if G were random in
this then finding I the little be given
this big random multiple of B plus some
little thing well that looks a lot like
problem 2 here you're given some
approximation to multiple of some secret
thing and you're given what that the
multiplier is and you're trying to find
the little beast so figuring out a
ciphertext if the key were random that
would be an example of this problem too
ok so now we've seen problem one once in
the public key so secret key recovery in
entró problem 2 and the secret key
recovery in the product and true end in
the decription or if they attack on the
messages in the entry system the
quotient and true and then problem 3
naturally appears in the encryption for
product and truth ring out of the you so
you're having as a public key you're
having a noisy multiple of some some AG
plus e sitting around there and then the
ciphertext you're getting a similar one
sent over so the sender also gives you a
b which is small and a deep and it also
takes the same be on your public key on
this a over there plus c ok then there's
also some message now she can solve
problem 3 over there and we get all the
message then problem 3 is exactly this
thing so distinguishing or finding B and
C and D here from these samples and this
is an example where they've whole
different distributions because I mean
the a is different from the gene
that's a g1q over here and then if you
can get that value well then you have
the ciphertext without the M you
subtract and you're getting the message
for people who want to prove stuff if
you want to formally define what these
problems are you have to start
distinguishing between the like the
search version of problem 3 and the
distinguishing version and similarly for
problem 2 and problem 1 and then
eventually you start being able to prove
something relating the crypto systems to
some sufficiently tedious versions of
these problems but for this attack talk
this will be enough diversity in these
problems ok so on the next slides I'm
stealing shamelessly from a paper the
den wrote and I'm feeling a little bit
like when you're in class and the kids
ask you hey is everything gonna be on
there on the exam and you say yes
everything that was on the slides will
be on the exam so and there's four more
of those I'm not going to read out any
of this but this is an attempt or
successful attempt because it says can
say that to squeeze all the letter space
systems from the NIST competition into
this framework so saying okay is this
product or quotient what are the
parameters where do we live so where do
these polynomials live so what ring we
have or what what module do we have and
then on the following slides so this
current will stroll over in every linus
is one system and so then what does
short mean so stream an intro prime that
was our example this line here so we're
living in this ring we're so that wasn't
Hugh this was the length and then over
here short means these coefficients that
weight and then for all the other ones
we have slightly different notions of
what short and what small means so if
you ever feel like ok you can't solve
problem two or three or you have a new
idea and you want to figure out how to
quickly map your targets go to that
paper and find this table there or go to
the slides to find the tables as well
and then some of those have entries such
as not applicable depending what they
can what's an encryption system somewhat
working with rounding somewhere using
what problem one two and time are using
two and three so there are some
differences there and yes it's all going
to be on the exam
the good thing is that once you've seen
a few of these problems then you rapidly
begin to get used to all of them from an
attack perspective so let's look at how
we can actually start breaking some of
these systems so just to again emphasize
this talk is about the attacks that
seemed to be the best that that people
know well what's called primal attacks
against these lattice systems for the
people who were there at the lattice
boot camp you heard an introduction to
primal attacks and that'll be fitting
within the framework but we're gonna
cover more of the attacks in this talk
typically people describe these primal
attacks as wow there's a bunch of
subroutines at the top you've got you
define some lattice based on the system
or one of these problems or more
precisely the exact crypto system you're
trying to to break and then well once
you've set up your lattice then you
apply say bkz beta some approximate SVP
algorithm which is internally using some
SVP algorithm and then all of this is
based on some model of computation this
talk is not going to be about the low
layers here although my next slide will
be one slide about models of computation
we are going to focus primarily at
what's going on at the top here
especially how you choose lattices and
how that interacts with the cost of
approximate SVP maybe I should also
mention when you really optimize these
things you start seeing the layers are
not exactly described by typical
statements of the approximate SVP you
shouldn't think about this layering as
some straitjacket and how you're
designing or analyzing algorithms there
can be interactions between the
different layers
all right so briefly one slide about
models of computation which which really
affects everything else and really it's
not just that it changes the exact
numbers of costs of things it'll often
tell you some algorithms are better than
others where you thought from a
different model of computation that the
other algorithm was better and so you
really have to be careful about what
your definitions are and also when
you're talking to users who are worried
about attackers who have some real model
you have to worry whether your model is
actually describing what the attacker
can do
typically for theoretical computer
science we'll start with say a multi
tape turing machine as a model of
computation or maybe a single tape but
single tape is like too wimpy it's too
slow
takes N squared time for lots of things
where you feel like wait I can do that
in linear time like sorting well a multi
tape turing machine if you have n
integers just as an example of how fast
this is i'm not going to give the formal
definitions but just to remind you of
the resulting speeds multi tape turing
machines feel kind of realistic if you
want to sort n numbers and h numbers
kind of small the total time you need is
basically n i'm suppressing this n to
the 1 plus little of 1 I'm suppressing
things like log factors and then the
space you need of course just to write
down the integers is and to the 1 but
also that's the total space for your
computation well in that amount of time
you wouldn't be able to get further than
that on your tapes these days in an era
of climate change we're also supposed to
worry about the energy cost of our
machines and for well before we get to
the 2d circuits let me just say on the
thanks on the multi tape turing machines
if you have a single tape then you can
have your tape your data sitting there
and the head of your machine is moving
along like one little energy unit for
each time step but as soon as you have
two tapes you can't do that anymore you
need energy to move your tapes and that
energy is linear in your tape lengths on
every step you need time n to move your
tapes of length n so your energy cost
here is actually the product of the time
and the space you have N squared energy
and then people started I'm sorry that's
right yeah yeah there is actually an
interesting if we ignore issues of
friction and stuff then yeah there is an
interesting section and Knuth sort of
computer programming about sorting on
tapes and one of the issues there is
like when you've got tapes moving then
same thing for disks to some extent when
you've got tapes moving then it's good
to read serially so you know you have
something having that momentum that is a
physical effect what you do notice
nevertheless if you build bigger and
bigger you know if you imagine n being
not just 2 to the 20 into 2 to the 50 to
the hundred you start seeing linear
effects from things like friction and
tape tension okay also I mean even a
laser doesn't nevermind um alright so
moving on to people started thinking
in the 70s and 80s already about ways to
model computation which would use the
hardware that you have available more
efficiently and use your energy more
efficiently I mean if you have to to the
50 to to the hundred units of storage
and one little CPU core sitting there
talking to that storage that's that
doesn't make sense compared to have you
know by billions of CPUs it's not going
to significantly add to your cost and
while Brenton King said our computation
is done on a big square array of
transistors connected by wires sounds
kind of realistic because well that's
how we do computations I maybe not once
we have quantum computers I mean you can
say hey this is still not the end of the
story but I mean they they said all
right they said this is not just reality
it's also a good theoretical definition
and they started proving theorems about
it like the a T squared is n squared
theorem for integer multiplication of n
bits or for sorting which is equivalent
that you can get your sorting time down
to sort of the distance across your chip
time some small constant and your space
of course for representing n numbers is
again and to the one your energy cost
looks like n to the one point five which
is much much better than N squared and
this is actually achieved through when
people do sorting records and men are
measure the time and energy it really
does follow this curve and you can
pinpoint what the little oval ones look
like it's not just some obscure
asymptotic result this is reality of
sorting today on big clusters energy is
n to the 1.5 so it's yeah like each spot
in your chip is using some energy at
each time unit okay you could say hey we
can get even better get down from
instead of a square root speed-up let's
get some exponential get down to a poly
love time for sorting if there's log
poly log bits in each integer using a
peer L now okay you have to be precise
if you want to prove theorems about P
grams say what exactly that means and
the definition is an interesting thing
that happened in the transition from
Turing trying to model physical
computation the development when it got
to P Rams also in the late 70s early 80s
the definitions stopped having arguments
that they were physical like this
is something you can actually implement
and if you imagine what it would take to
sort to to the hundred items we could
barely imagine storing those but if you
imagine sorting to to the hundred items
in time almost constant that doesn't
make any physical sense but well you can
still define this and you can analyze
this and lots of people do analyze
algorithms in appearance and then you
can do all this again for quantum
computers so for quantum computers
people have defined for instance you can
define quantum 2d circuits which are
more powerful as far as we can tell than
normal 2d circuits and quote you can
define some more parallel quantum things
or less parallel quantum things and you
must get these definitions right if you
want to do serious algorithm analysis of
lattice attacks all right
so lettuces I mean this talk is about
lattices so how do we get from the
problems one two three that we have on
the board conveniently for eternity to
anything looking like lettuce so we're
trying to find something with this short
and reminding you so a was the short
thing was fixed Wade he was a general
short thing and so for these it doesn't
actually matter that they're mod Q
because I mean they're just zero plus
minus one for the G it does matter and
for the solution by given here okay
proper problem one it's zero but this is
also a statement in our mod Q Dan is
always this problem - all right so a
problem - the difficulty here is this
word homogeneous I mean problem one was
was given as a homogeneous equation in
Ag plus Z equals zero but for problem
two we're given you'd want to say well
find an A and an e which have AG plus e
equal to this other thing we're given
but that's not homogeneous it's in
homogeneous so clever mathematics here
you homogenize put in an extra variable
so now you've got a homogeneous equation
which I mean the solution you're looking
for of course is the short a short e and
T equals 1 all right and then for
problem three once we mask the problem -
it's again the same so we stuffing in
the T 1 same is here and there's T 2
here so if you haven't in a Magina
system if it's not equal to zero you
homogenize it by adding in extra
variables so here we're just in our -
for our solution here we are three where
the one variable comes from having this
T extra
and here we're now down to our five then
turn this into lettuce so basically
having this map there that we turn a
vector a comma R into this vector enter
what happens is that the first part so
we make mapping our a bar and our bar
times the 2x2 matrix and then the first
one is just the identity so we have in
the first quadrant here we have I and
the our doesn't get used at all so this
0 here and in the second part we have Q
times R so giving it Q times identity
matrix here and we have a minus a times
G so we have this G thing now written as
a matrix so there's there's one step in
there how we turned from the rings that
we have over there into matrices and so
what we have there is a polynomial
multiplication with the reduction in
this case what do this polynomial of 7th
degree 7 at 61 and in general you have
your structure either cyclic don't make
or it's like with the plus in the middle
and so you can always write this as a
matrix multiplication where you have
basically the polynomial times first row
we see constant term then the extra X
square and so on till X to the N minus X
to the degree minus 1 okay and then you
have you nice lettuce here and thanks to
Alice we already have seen how to deal
with lettuces while which actually
modules because these are elements over
our time for problem - so problem - well
you do the same thing where you're
thinking of that the e that you're
looking for in the end that's supposed
to be modulo Q it's supposed to be the
secret a times G E Plus E oops minus 80
that's supposed to be eat and the final
thing and here this is no more mod Q we
have to explicitly say what that that
extra variable is so okay the image of
this map is exactly the yeah of course
to define this you have to lift G like
tanya was mentioning take say between 0
and Q minus 1 for all the coefficients
lift G from our mod Q R and then this
map has image exactly the solutions to
this equation
modulo Q and then you're just trying to
find a short vector in that lattice of
rank three times they took me okay and
then problem three just the same just
going up from from three barrel to five
variables again putting in the Q's - to
do the lifting and everything stays the
same now how do you break these and then
was already referred to Martin's torque
from the boot camp and I was referring
to Alice's talk this morning so we have
these are modules and can look at them
as legacies but we have some extra
structure here so we can use this extra
structure to find not just one solution
because we do know that this a comma E
or this a T and E and so on depending
which problem you're looking at we know
that there's at least one short solution
but once you have one short solution
because of the algebraic structure in
here you're getting lots of independent
short vectors for instance the problem -
we have this short vector but if you
multiply by X okay for the normal entry
letters where you're computing
motorcylce Tomic polynomial or with X to
the P plus 1 minus 1 you basically just
shifting around so this has the same
weight as this one for intra prime it's
a little bit worse because at some point
you're reaching the degrees 7 had 61 and
then you turning the extras 701 into X
plus 1 instead of just 1 so the degree
goes up a little bit but it's still very
short and then you multiply by x squared
and you're getting for each of those
getting short right or he can do linear
combinations of those for instance you
can take x
yeah those didn't make it on the walk
before right sorry
you can also do like linear combinations
you can take the original vector Plus
this vector also known as you multiply
by X plus 1 and so you get another short
vector so these give you fairly short
combinations and so just by knowing that
there's one finally one of them gives
you a solution and also for the attacks
it doesn't really matter which one you
find so if you were finding this as your
short solution that is equivalent in the
breaking to that one Princeton's if you
look at
affection Lizzie is a quotient and true
the ex just falls out and else you're
getting everything's good big question
yes to that
that wouldn't be homogeneous over our so
these it yeah yeah but I mean at the
moment we're still living over our so
everything you every Beck extra variable
you introduce gives you an extra
variable over our and so the natural
modernization gives you this thing we
get to by God was in a moment if that's
what you're thinking about we're getting
to by gal growth in a moment if you
think about it I'm just saying this is
just our effect of the particular
homogeneous Asian sure you can throw
away solutions a few shoes to I mean
they all exist on the way to a lettuce
you homogenize and this is erectus a
modular over R so this is the natural
way of harmonization
so throwing away mulch is often a good
idea so there's a paper by Alex my and
just suffer men in order to reduce the
degree or reduce the dimension because
all the letters of texts that are not
topic of this talk but of course we have
to to live with the larger that I
mention of our letters the longer these
are texts or the longer these algorithms
takes and so it's often a good idea to
put some of the variables to zero in
particularly in our a over there we know
that a is small and very restricted in
weight out of all the 761 positions only
286 are nonzero so the weight is very
very low and so it's a good idea to say
hey we're putting some of them to zero
the rank will go down so it's gonna be
smaller by exactly that number which
we're fixing and so the letters will be
faster of course we might have been
wrong in that maybe one of those
positions was not zero so it's a
question whether it's always a speed up
and well it just means if it's not a
speed up you have to check where
parameters are living probably this one
number I give you next it's not always
the right one but for instance here oh I
have a 13 on the next slide with his
exact numbers which looks good here but
it's also as a function not just of the
length but also of the size of Q and
it's when you don't know that the secret
is small so that would be like you have
you didn't restrict
a to be small and then you take two
samples and then you basically convert
into one and do back all right that
gives you that kind of alright so since
I've mentioned like I wasn't already so
what they are doing is basically going
the same direction as Chris mentioned in
his question you look at this thing save
us problem twos you have let us so start
with our to the three so you're having
this three dimensions over R so three
times seven and 61 and then he says well
we're forcing many of the positions of a
to zero so same as my Superman and most
of the positions of T to zero so many
that only T
has degree one I saw it's constant so T
equals one so that basically moves as
homogenization it's no longer
homogeneous over R it is homogeneous
over Z and so it's a valid step but it
is reducing a lot from seven and sixty
one to just one that is nice for the
dimension of your letters but it also
removes a lot of the symmetries and the
symmetries can be nice because all of
those solutions were there and suddenly
by this one choice they're all gone so
again the same question is as always
faster definitely it looks like if the
queue gets large there's not a question
to answer but by geography by Galbraith
naturally fits into this system
basically is a specialization of my
servants idea
alright so stand analysis has already
promised let's look at some concrete
numbers so now we're back to the problem
one for the extrema inter Prime so 7 and
61 letters weight or something well 268
or 2 and 1686 not 9 almost were 1217 and
then just probably one so we have 2
times the degree of the polynomial so 2
times 7 or 61 as a dimension of this
letters and then you're going to apply
the my sliver minute idea to this and
we're gonna force some positions to 0
now our II that was not restricted in
waited was just restricted in size so
basically two thirds are going to be
plus or minus one and one-third is going
to be 0 so if you look at the nuclear
norm then it's probably about scroll of
that so about 23:23 of that but that's
just taken the average value and we
don't know I mean the ears randomly
chosen it can be more extreme on the
larger side on the smaller side and then
will it change the security analysis to
do fixed weight for this which intro
initially did instrument enter prime is
saying roll e we taking a larger
solution space or a larger problem space
and so we don't restrict this
that also means that we're looking at a
different distribution so I mean we
didn't email all those in for the open
problem session but we have lots of open
problems on the slides in general people
are reading the slides that the
parenthetical comments you see basically
each parenthetical comment is at least
one open question sometimes
contradicting questions like what is
smaller what is larger we really I mean
this is an open question which we are
interested in seeing and yeah now it's
about you so if you take notes or we can
just I mean we don't have the slides
online afterwards okay so in my Silliman
was supposed to put some of the
variables to zero say for instance we're
putting 13 variables to zero that means
out of the 761 shoes to and 86
we now have while only 761 minus 13 and
then choose 2 and 69 and so the fraction
of those two is a probability of 0.2
percent that means forcing those 13
positions to be 0 has reduced our chance
that this actually finds it because well
these 13 might have been having at least
one which is not 0 on the other hand our
rank is much smaller at the degrees much
more of a down from 1522 to 1509 so then
it depends on the speed of the lettuce
attack whether this is an improvement or
not and if not well this is the
parameter to change I mean if it was too
many if it was too few you can't play
with her probability if you have a very
fast let us attack I mean in Elsa's talk
there was like let's assume we can
magically solve for CBP this is not a
good thing I mean if you can't solve SBP
CVP then you're done you don't need this
but if you have a realistic cost you can
tune with this drama
and as I said already the tag is also
happy to get rotations of this or
multiplications by X so any of the short
ones are fine for the fortune ones the
exporters fall out in else well you will
probably notice with something that you
have a multiplication by X sitting round
so the standard analysis so you have
this probability of the 0.2% of being in
those letters where you have first
forced some of the positions to be 0 and
then let me just repeat this with
different choices do we just get we have
tried this 5 times do we now get 1%
probability let's just assume that they
are but in this case it's less lesser
questions more like a comment they're
not really independent the probability
depends a lot on where we are for
instance if you're thinking of the
enterprise that is where you have the
spillover effect that the 761 turns into
X plus 1
you're probably happier to four zeros up
there because then you are also reducing
the spillover so it's not exactly the
right thing but it's it's getting close
for the estimates bigger solutions so
other multipliers I had the X plus 1 on
the slides before how hard is it to find
those how likely is it to find those so
that's another interesting question and
then I mentioned already a few times
this is actually not the right of
reduction so the normal reduction for n
true it's like two Tomic the polynomial
then it is easier with the rotations
here you're getting all this extra
factors alright back to our problems
so we have our problem two statement up
there so we have our in homogenous
solution we have these equations on the
coefficients and then we also want to
reduce our latest dimension a bit
further so we take our ring and just
saying hey we forget about the ring
structure well it's kind of behind
because we were would be happy with x
times a but let's forget about this for
the moment we want to throw our
preferred as a piece over onto this and
so then we have these 761 equations and
then we have another parameter in
addition to the fixing some of the
parameters of a to be 0 we know
want to project onto something so we're
fixing 600 on to issue a projecting so
we reducing our letters dimension by
another 161 and then we're getting a
different rank of those letters and so I
have my my matrix here and so that just
means that I'm cutting out 161 of the
equations so instead of having
determinant here to the 7 and 61 I am
reducing my determinant to only Q to the
600 which is nice for therefore the run
time and well it gets smaller and then I
also want to kind of push because I know
that my a is small I put some extra
weight on there so I do some reading
typical rescaling is such that the these
two parts are balanced so the normal
weight in the 'part is that I'm having
well there was this random choice
between plus and minus 1 so that gave me
the square root of 21 which was larger
squirt of length thing 2/3 of the length
thing which was 23 which is larger than
the 17 which is the average weight or
it's the exact weight of our small value
over here so the a which is guaranteed
to be small this has norm about 17 and
the e on average has norm 23 and so it's
tough and the scaling factor this lambda
and the standard choice is to choose
that these bounds out so the way W which
is what I have in my a and then lambda
should give me the same 23 that I have
in the e part it's as optimal it's in
the standard analysis I might want to
balance this a little bit and this is
also a comes in that II might have
larger or smaller norm this has just
taken the average norm but if a thing of
like wikis or corner cases we soon as
many percent of probability my AE will
be much shorter or much longer and it
could also be interesting to develop an
attack which finds those faster so
there's interaction with the size of the
sea all right last part on this thing
that was like the boss yeah I'll be
getting into the real thing yeah so so
there's all these choices in setting up
a lattice and then you throw it over the
wall to somebody who's willing to give
you short vectors and lattices well I
can't find super-short but you asked
them to find some as short as they can
afford to do while the afford is defined
by this beta parameter there's some bkz
beta you make beta as big as you can
subject to your time limit cost limit
and then using that algorithm you reduce
the basis that you had after whatever
transformations tanya was mentioning and
then well maybe because he's not the
best algorithm there's several different
algorithms which all maybe have about
the same performance but just saying
well yeah there's some reason to think
that they're all kind of similar doesn't
mean they're actually similar but let's
do let's ignore that this is not really
a talked about details of choices that
you can make at this layer but do want
to emphasize what can go wrong with the
analysis first step of the bkz part of
the standard analysis so maybe I should
say it's standard analysis this is what
you find in basically all of the NIST
submissions the NIST submissions are
following the the pattern that we've
been talking about maybe leaving out
some of the options like setting up
lattices in a more general way than by
Galbreath to use the our module
structure but everybody follows this
this basic pattern and then does the
following they say vkz beta will find a
vector of about this length there's some
funky formula for Delta and then
normally bkz beta does that what does
normally mean nobody wants to say that
they'll say it's this is the expected
length of the vector will expected what
sort of distribution do you get it's
actually even worse than not knowing
like how the distribution is around this
length it's this formula is wrong this
formula has been repeatedly disproven by
every experiment that people have
carried out it's I mean they there's
there's a thesis which is now online
where you can find the asymptotic
argument for this formula being about
write as beta goes to infinity but
there's no bounce there's nothing saying
that you know even if you believe the
asymptotic there's nothing saying here's
how close Delta should get to this beta
formula as beta goes up so what's the
right formula
open question there's some things called
sandpile models where people are trying
to develop algorithms which will compute
the right Delta and maybe those models
are accurate at least the latest one
saying here's some inaccuracies in the
previous ones but they're also very very
slow and so nobody uses them to analyze
algorithms and then you keep going on
the bkz analysis next thing people say
is well there's this geometric decrease
of the gram-schmidt sizes and well this
assumption it's kind of about correct
based on a bunch of experiments except
that well it's not really when when
people do experiments and they look
closely than they find ya know you can
every experiment if you look closely
enough you can detect that the
assumption is wrong it may be not wrong
enough to matter but well it's hard to
tell people don't do that analysis the
standard analysis just says yeah that's
correct which in turn gives you via
another arguments um this is what people
call the 2016 estimate which was shown
experimentally to be wrong in 2017 which
says if your vector is a small as blah
then you will find it sorry for which
part well this let's see this was Martin
and I I'm afraid I don't remember
offhand the list of authors but I mean
you would remember offhand their graphs
their graphs so I mean if you look at
the graphs in the paper which report the
results of the experiments then you
clearly see that the this statement that
the which is the statement used in the
analyses which says that you find a
vector if and only if the length of
Western equal Dubois the experiments
show that sometimes when beta satisfies
this when beta is chosen to satisfy this
you do not find the vector so that
contradicts this furthermore sometimes
when beta is chosen even a bit larger
you do not find it that's also shown in
the experiments furthermore sometimes
when beta is a little smaller faster
attack then the experiments will
sometimes find the vector the same paper
has the beginnings of an analysis which
explains why this formula is wrong so I
agree that the experiments are saying
this is
kinda-sorta correct but it's not saying
that this is correct it's saying it's
kinda sorta correct yeah about three
percent of the time sounds reasonable
thats on a randomized experiment
sometimes you might get it slightly and
back yet think it's a bit unfair to say
that formula is wrong well there there's
this is the statement which is assumed
in the standard analysis and the
parenthetical comment here is that the
experiments identified deviations from
this statement now if you say that the
deviations are kind of small then I
agree depending how you measuring the
deviations are I mean this the beta that
you get out of this analysis it's
probably within a few percent of the
right beta
however consequences of getting this
kind of analysis wrong are for example
that you end up concluding that hybrid
attacks are only effective for certain
parameter ranges and that conclusion is
not justified in fact at the end of the
talk we're going to formulate a theory
saying that that conclusion is always
wrong and the reason that people got to
that conclusion was exactly this kind of
mistake in doing analyses this I mean it
this is saying there's a sharp wall and
you're saying well yeah it's kinda sorta
around there yeah it seems like it from
the experiments but the experiments
clearly show that you don't get such a
sharp transition and exactly that effect
is what hybrid attacks can exploit I
mean you could also if you have a secret
or never come just from a Gaussian
distribution discrete Gaussian there is
a nonzero probability that your vector
is so long all of these analysis we
agree there's a probabilistic aspect to
this and beyond that I mean the the
argument for this is saying if you take
a sort of typical vector and you feed it
through certain transformations going
through your your thought is a ssin then
for instance in a nearest plane
computation you it's
same thing then this is Chi what you get
some kind of expected size of the result
and you compare that to your your
geometric series and say well yeah this
is when you're gonna find things and I
mean that that's sort of a good ballpark
estimate but if you actually want to
understand how fast the attacks are and
you want to get you know optimized the
right things understand which algorithms
are useful speed ups then you have to be
more careful with the analysis and not
just say you know it's if and only if
and I mean this really is the statement
you see in the standard analysis that
you find the vector if and only if the
lengths is less than equal to that that
is the 2016 statement and it's just not
true there's there's a consensus
analysis which is used to produce a
bunch of numbers which are supposed to
be security analyses and that consensus
analysis starts from this statement
which you find for example in the 2016
New Hope paper and this statement is
disproven by experiments and then you
can say well you know how far off is it
that's the open question is to
understand how far off this is this is
so in wonderous thesis in 2018 there's a
pretty clear explanation in the context
of nearest plane of why various
estimates from 2017 2016 etc are wrong
and he has a better formula which seems
very plausible and if you adapt that
from the nearest plane context to this
context then you get a probabilistic
curve which seems to match the
experiments and that's also again the
beginnings of that are in this 2017
paper but that still doesn't mean that
that's right it's it's sort of you know
it's at least not obviously everybody
agrees it's in the right ballpark that's
not the point of this view the point of
dispute is this overly precise statement
which then leads people to make
incorrect conclusions about for example
hybrid attack and the the open question
is to get it right
I totally agree that the 2017 paper and
then in more detail that 2018 thesis
from him is saying what fuels like the
right analysis I mean there's yeah it's
not that it's not he's claiming a
theorem but I mean it's the formula
seems plausible but that I that doesn't
mean that this question is solidly
answered it just means that there's a
not disproven 2018 thesis on it yeah
okay you only have five minutes left
yeah so then if if you get through all
this the standard analysis then says
that well you you find the vector the
short American you want assuming that
the the lattice transformations of Tonya
mentioned didn't throw it away and if
well so then you now have this
probabilistic thing that maybe worked
depending on choices you made in setting
up the lattice and then people say well
you try it again one over P times where
previous the probability of this working
but that's making some independence
assumption which is already disproven in
the my silverman paper it's also
implicitly assuming that every time you
go through the algorithm you're choosing
the parameters the same which doesn't
make sense if for instance E is kind of
smaller or larger than you were thinking
for your average estimate maybe you
should be increased in the parameters as
you go through or decreasing unclear or
I mean just an example of one word in
this talk being something that can make
a significant difference there are NIST
submissions where if you simply say wait
it's not divided by P for quantum
algorithms that's divided by square root
of P because you can do a Grover search
that makes a 12 bit difference in the
security estimate for one of the NIST
submissions so I mean these these
questions and we made a list of dozens
and dozens and dozens of these issues
and analyses and any particular one
maybe it's only two or three bits
getting things wrong but these things
pile up there it would be good to maybe
even one I mean no guarantees you might
not get a paper out of it yeah but maybe
all right the cost of bkz well the
standard analysis says use Civic takes
exponent point two nine two times beta
this is fake math it was never justified
in the first place the point two nine
two comes from an asymptotic which says
0.29 two plus something that converges
to zero every experiment has said that
little of one is something positive
nobody's sure exactly how it's
increasing
I mean how this expression is increasing
with beta it is reasonably convincing
that as beta goes to infinity the number
in front of it converges to point two
nine two but that never justified
crossing out the little of one and
putting in zero the reason that people
choose this particular sitting algorithm
rather than enumeration is that they
take this fake point two nine to beta
number and compare it to an experimental
extrapolation from say sand pile models
which gives you a point one eight seven
one over to me I guess and then a
somewhat harder to explain numbers after
that for the cost of enumeration but if
you compare some even if the
extrapolations right if you compare that
to a fake number doesn't mean that the
algorithm with the fake analysis is
faster maybe it is maybe it's not it's
possible yes that I mean if you plug in
a fake number for your standard analysis
and if nobody can actually write down an
algorithm that's that fast
you would guess that the security levels
are higher and then oh oh it can be
totally a problem because if you're
telling users your security levels are
down here and what they want is
something up here then they end up
taking your system and throwing it away
and then they move to something else and
that's something else maybe you've
estimated it badly in a different way or
maybe they say this cryptographic stuff
is something I can't afford so it's it's
not that just under estimating security
by random amounts for different systems
is going to give you a secure
cryptographic system the users have
choices of cryptographic systems and we
should be both intellectually and for
the application to crypto as accurate as
possible
I'm sorry I depending which paper you
look at there will often be statement
saying that the point 292 is an under
estimate and it's clearly not something
that algorithms are going to achieve
which doesn't at all address the issue
that I just said we want to get the
right number the open is to get the
right number did I say that something
was dishonest I was just saying I was
just saying that plugging in a sum
number into this point 292 when the it
was never justified the justification
was simply saying let's just hope that
little of one is zero
I mean it could be that point two nine
two is bigger saying it's a lower bound
suggests to me there's no theorem
maybe a little of one is negative the
experiments don't seem to go that way
but the point is there was never a
justification for this point two nine
two an experiment say it should be
something else so open question is
figure out what the right thing is
instead of discarding other algorithms
because they seem to be worse than this
this is a talk which is presenting open
questions and now I could use icing
everything everyone is trying to do what
you're not doing anything on the topic
it's this little talk which is going
through a bunch of algorithms and saying
here are open questions regarding the
performance of these algorithms and you
seem offended by this this numbers fake
yeah I mean that this particular one is
not a reasonable I mean this is
scientifically never justified there's
there's lots of things where people say
this is an estimate and we have some
justification for it like this one
people say how they get to this
extrapolation but this point - and I -
is just I mean it's it's fake math it's
really
it's not an inequality it is a guess
it's a speculation that the little of
one is depending what you're looking at
zero or greater than equal to zero it
seems from experiments that the
statement said it's greater than or
equal to zero are for the sizes of
experiments justified but it it's really
you know you can make any number of
different formulas which have the same
asymptotic as this and then yeah I was
hoping we would get two hybrids instead
of dealing with people being offended at
their work not being perfect but how do
we deal with this session chair you are
in charge of everything that's funny
just move through this slide so we can
show the numbers at least yeah it's sad
to not get to the hybrid yeah I mean
there was some actual content which we
were hoping to get to beyond I think the
appeal that we were doing here is please
state what you're modeling please state
where you're doing lower bounds upper
bounds putting stuff to zero when you're
getting a number so in our submission we
actually ended up putting all numbers in
saying okay depending on which model
you're doing these are the best costs
we're getting for saving or enumeration
depending on whether you're doing hybrid
or non hybrid and so at least you can
say hey I have improved your number in
the saving context from this to
something else and so for those we're
saying okay here are the the estimates
and the restrictions are putting in and
it's mostly an appeal to say hey look
when you're putting a 0 of 1 to 0 say
well here's the evidence because we
assuming we're looking at experiments
and it seems to be positive and so we're
doing a conservative or under estimate
or as I said less than equal to
statement there and we're assuming here
for therefore the other costs that it's
exact so whatever so these are our
numbers now interestingly is we went for
memory cost and realistic memory costs
were we saying okay well if you have
memory if you have to pay for your
memory then then was motivation they
motivated the computational model and so
it gets more expensive and that hits for
instance sitting a lot harder than
numeration for in
raishin we don't see any difference in
the cost for memory with between free
and real was for saving it changes the
attack levels a lot now columns here
this column here is the pre quantum this
column here gives you a Grover and so
for instance if something were you
looking for a collision somewhere then
Grover gives you a squared speed up in
those things and then you do see in the
enumeration context here in the real
memory model that does get cheaper and
otherwise they're not so many
differences then hits something prepared
for hybrid attacks without quantum
computers so let's say we skip the
slides but let me just make one comment
about it which is that the the lines
where you see hybrid attacks
apparently not making a difference like
208 to 208 or 153 to 153 sometimes they
do make a difference but those I want
you to remember this talk formulating
the theory that those are all
calculation errors in the standard
analysis so even with our efforts to
correct the various problems it's only
this year that I would say we've
identified the error that led to that it
seems in the summation it's not in your
submissions and our submission view
think the highways should be faster well
which also means an author sub so the
theory the theory is that yeah I mean
for where we're saying you know like I
mean this one 208 for instance not
getting faster with hybrid attacks that
appears to be a calculation error from
the standard analysis here being more
wrong than the standard analysis here
and when that's corrected then it seems
that there's a little bit of a gap and
yes that would also apply to other
submissions this is I mean this is work
in progress it's just an error that
we've identified this year but it could
be that every submission is affected by
hybrid attacks now that's not confident
claim just theory that we've formulated
that hybrid attacks always improve the
attack picture all right and then we'll
skip those slots though thanks for
attention
[Applause]
[Music]
right I think it's time so we wear one
more top crease in it do you want to say
something that if you just remove the
word fake and kind of ignore that level
of dispute I mean it's really in a very
important point so it's not just in this
competition so homework at the
encryption standardization is a huge
effort it's a super technology they have
to get these numbers right we we have we
all know that there's a lot of different
options for modeling the cost and I
think like one meta point we could take
from this is we just need more work in
this direction so I just want to iterate
you know reinforce what you're what I
see is your global point okay so let's
take it that's a 20 minute coffee break
pill will resume at photo five stop and
then the open problem
[Music]